[Musique]
bonsoir a tous vu ce lundi 9 juillet
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce statut et du
journal le discours d' emmanuel macron
devant le congrès à versailles le
président de la république a convoqué
pour la deuxième fois de son mandat
sénateurs et députés une prise de parole
pour annoncer les grands chantiers des
réformes à venir
elle nous serons sur place au début de
cette édition week-end de grands départs
en vacances environ 200000 juillettistes
ont emprunté l'autoroute a10 samedi et
dimanche
direction le sud pendant cette période
le peloton de gendarmerie de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines est pleinement
mobilisé reportage au coeur d'une
opération de contrôle routier
et puis elle également a fait son grand
départ un grand départ vers la retraite
anne-marie cruz a quitté ses fonctions
de directrice de l'école de lavilledieu
à elancourt où elle exerçait et depuis
12 ans nous avons suivi vendredi sa
dernière journée dans l'établissement
invité de ce journal également guillaume
dordet du syndicat alliance police
nationale des yvelines nous parlerons
avec lui tout à l'heure de l'actualité
autour de la police un discours de près
d'une heure trente devant les
parlementaires emmanuel macron a réuni
aujourd'hui en congrès à versailles les
parlementaires les députés et sénateurs
français
le président de la république a détaillé
le calendrier des prochaines réformes
refondre notamment le régime des
retraites baisser la dépense publique
mise en place aussi d'un plan pauvreté
le chef de l'état également a défendu
son bilan nicolas kirillovitch bonsoir
vous avez suivi ce discours d' emmanuel
macron oui bonsoir grégory vous le
disiez 1h30 discours sur la forme c'est
un peu plus long que prévu sur le fond
c'est ce qui est est attendue de la part
du président il revenu sur ce qui a été
fait cette année les réformes lancé
celle qui vont se mettre en place à
partir de l'automne et pour 2019 parmi
celles ci la réforme des retraites
l'assurance chômage
et puis il a aussi répondu à ses
critiques qui se fait un l'attend
désormais depuis quelques semaines sur
ce volet social qui manqueraient à son
action il a rappelé que
il n'y avait pas d'un côté l'économie et
de l'autre le social nous sommes avec
j'ai envie de dire presque le local de
l'étape didier baichère député de cette
circonscription est ici à versailles et
vous qu'est ce que vous avez retenu de
ce discours d'une heure et demie du
plaisir de la république c'est un
discours qui était fort est en même
temps empreint d'humilité parce qu'à
plusieurs reprises il est revenu en
disant qu'on ne peut pas tout faire en
une année qui comprenait aussi que le
rythme des réformes importantes qui ont
été engagés par l'assemblée nationale
pouvait parfois être mal comprise ou que
le temps passé très très vite c'est
qu'il fasse et qu'il fallait prendre ce
temps de la pédagogie
moi j'ai retenu un discours
effectivement très social il est revenu
à de très nombreuses reprises même pour
l'éducation en insistant en fait sur le
volet de vouloir sortir les jeunes de
leur quartier et c'est pour ça qu'on
fait le par exemple dédoublement des
classes de cp et de ce1
on a beaucoup insisté sur la lutte
contre la pauvreté la précarité qui sera
un enjeu de l'année 2010 9,1 à la même
cité créé l'état providence du 21e
siècle
en parlant également de la dépendance
qui va être un grand sujet de l'année
est-ce qu'on peut pas continuer à voir
les familles face à l isolement de nos
aînés et ça va être un très très grand
chantier de l'année 2009 avec les
retraites c'est que ce discours
permettra d'étendre les critiques qui
commencent à apparaître au sein même de
la majorité sur ce manque justement
d'action sociale du président ce
président qui semble très attiré par le
volet économique est peu par le volet
social ce que vous pensez que ça va
suffire à atteindre ces critiques ce
qu'il faut c'est bien comprendre que
l'ensemble des réformes en fait c'est un
bloc c'est un bloc compact et quand on
parle des entreprises c'est pas pour
opposer les entreprises et les salariés
quand on parle de la précarité c'est pas
pour opposer les riches et les pauvres
donc encore une fois il ya une cohérence
dans l'ensemble des mesures et il a très
bien réexpliquer sur ce qui s'est passé
pendant l'année écoulée
il fallait démarrer par redonner de
l'agilité aux entreprises parce que s'il
n'y a pas d'emploi on va pas pouvoir
travailler la précarité la lutte contre
la précarité s'est pas donné des
nouvelles aides sociales aux gens pour
qu'ils restent là où ils sont dans leur
quartier ou dans leurs difficultés
c'est les aider vers l'inclusion
économique et les aider à trouver un
emploi
en l'occurrence et pour ça on a besoin
des entreprises et donc on est vraiment
dans une cohérence des politiques et on
va dire deux moments particuliers lors
de ce discours notamment
de l'hommage rendu aux forces armées
militaires et puis aux policiers
gendarmes sur le terrain en france et
puis aussi on a l'impression un peu ce
coup réussi contre les critiques avec ce
projet d'amendement sur le projet de loi
constitutionnelle pour permettre au
prochain congrès donc en juillet 2019 au
président de la république de répondre
aux élus aux parlementaires est ce que
vous pensez c'est un coup réussi là
dessus de la part du président c'était
un coup de communication un peu réussi
je pense que c'est dans l'ordre des
choses c'est à dire que on est avec un
président qui respecte ses engagements
qui a dit qu'il viendrait faire le bilan
chaque année devant le congrès de
l'action engagée et donné les
perspectives pour l'année suivante
donc ça me semble important que le
dialogue puisse s'engager avec les
parlementaires et les sénateurs qui sont
là donc c'est pas du tout d'un coup de
com' c'est tout simplement organiser le
dialogue de manière sereine et qu'on
puisse répondre et dialoguer avec le
président sur les soldats je pense que
fin les soldats les gendarmes la police
c'est aussi un moment solennel quand on
est au congrès parce qu on sait qu on
s'est réunis au congrès dans des moments
difficiles et je trouve ça important
qu'on puisse leur rendre hommage
parce qu'au quotidien il sauve des vies
il accompagne nos familles nous protège
et c'est toujours très important de
pouvoir souligner de l'importance du
travail qu'ils font voilà grégory sur ce
que l'on pouvait dire du congrès on
verra si ce discours a des effets très
rapidement puisque demain le projet de
loi constitutionnelle est discutée à
l'assemblée il ya la conférence des
territoires et puis aussi cette
conférence sociale annoncée pour le 17
juillet prochain
merci nicolas kirillovitch depuis
versailles vous étiez avec patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les moyens
techniques
ce week-end c'était la première à la
grande salle des départs pour les
vacances d'été environ deux cent mille
voitures ont emprunté l'autoroute a10
depuis l'île de france direction la
province le peloton de gendarmerie de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines étaient
mobilisés entre sanctions prévention et
sécurisation retour sur la matinée de
samedi au plus haut du pic de
circulation sur l'a10
un reportage de nicolas d'andrus trafic
routier dense sur l'autoroute a10 pour
ce premier week-end de départ en
vacances les gendarmes sont sur le pont
jumelles ou ultra light différents
outils pour contrôler la vitesse sur un
axe limité à 130 kilomètres heure
[Applaudissements]
oui
contre la poursuite du véhicule s'engage
le conducteur obtempère et suit les
gendarmes jusqu'à une issue de service
pour procéder à la verbalisation
vous avez été contrôlé à la vitesse
pourtant 72 km n'a pas été inscrit juste
et c'est bon pour la vitesse
soixante dix
vous allez faire l'objet d'un procès
verbal le conducteur en infraction
recevra une amende de 90 euros
il devrait perdre trois points sur son
permis de conduire en ce jour de départs
les personnes voulaient assez vite car
ils ont qu'une envie c'est d'arriver sur
leur lieu de vacances c'était très chaud
c'est insupportable
donc les personnes abus sur leur vitesse
comme aujourd'hui on a eu 1 172 km/h
autre mission des gendarmes lors des
grands départs faire de la prévention et
assurer la sécurité dans des situations
dangereuses
au point de voir avec lui arrêté sur la
bande d'arrêt d'urgence donc en plus
d'amateurs d'art tunnels donc faire
attention on va aller voir où dort et
surtout en situation de vacances comme
ça c'est fréquent aussi bien au niveau
casse moteur
les personnes à bord doit de sortir du
véhicule nous construire et et se mettre
ainsi que
j'espère de sécurité
faire que des bananes sont pas sans
suite
c'est sympa tu voyais c'était une zone
de sécurité pour m déjà les personnes en
sécurité et nous-mêmes fallait vraiment
vulnérable à ce moment là ruth les gens
ils sont tous enfants de kilomètres
heure donc si ça tape
bagdad ap tout simplement les gendarmes
du peloton de saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
ont constaté depuis le début de l'année
un décès sur l'autoroute a10 en cause un
véhicule arrêté sur le côté de la voie
suite à une panne on accueille sur ce
plateau guillaume dordet bonfort vous
êtes secrétaire régional adjoint du
syndicat alliance police nationale des
yvelines avec vous on évoque l'actualité
autour de la police dans le département
notamment la police de sécurité du
quotidien déployés dès cet automne à
trappes
parlons d'abord d'un autre sujet c'est
un rapport qui a été dressé par la
commission d' enquête du sénat sur
l'état du moral des forces de l'ordre un
constat alarmant des conclusions
inquiétantes le rapport parle d'un
malaise extrêmement profond a beaucoup
de difficultés rencontrées au quotidien
comment vous avez accueilli ce rapport
mais disons que dans un premier temps
déjà alliance police nationale se
félicite de la clairvoyance des
dessinateurs qui en mille doit justement
sur ce que nous dénonçons pas depuis
plusieurs années dans l'ordre et
plusieurs années que vous dénoncez ce
genre de choses tu as fait le constat
pointent du doigt notamment un taux de
suicide supérieur chez les policiers par
rapport à la moyenne nationale 36 %
supérieur et moyenne nationale un mal
être psychologique des équipements
vétustes -o qui est aussi un problème
sur les heures supplémentaires qui ne
serait pas payer 22 millions d'heures
supplémentaires non payées
selon la commission denquête un rapport
alarmiste est il réaliste ce rapport oui
c'est alarmant mais en fait ce n'est pas
surprenant
en fait on est déjà au courant de tous
et de soussa de tous ces problèmes là
après malheureusement on ne peut pas
c'est difficile de trouver une solution
pour 16 heures supplémentaires après il
va falloir trouver forcément une
solution pour pour pour les problèmes un
mal être psychologique aussi dit ce
rapport c'est 2017 vous avez vu qu'il ya
cinquante et un policiers qui se sont
donné la mort donc c'est très
regrettable et on espère vraiment que on
va dans le bon sens et en fait on ne
demande une
une solution pourrait apporter pour pour
aider justement les policiers parce que
c'est pas facile tous les jours
nous sommes vos autres danses opposant
douter gains donc on demande une un
suivi psychologique qui peut être
important
le climat actuel est aussi tendue on
pense forcément aux attentats le meurtre
du couple de policiers il ya deux ans à
magnanville encore ce week-end un
automobiliste a foncé sur des policiers
à vernouillet foncé en voiture ça
renforce aussi ce mal être psychologique
il ya un climat tendu actuellement il ya
bien sûr avec l'actualité que nous avons
eue il ya deux ans ici dans l'est dans
les yvelines
forcément ça a changé vraiment quelque
chose sur la façon de travailler de nos
collègues on est beaucoup plus méfiant
mes collègues sont beaucoup plus
méfiants et c'est vrai qu'il ya une
certaine appréhension qu'on avait
peut-être pas avant et maintenant ça
devient vraiment malheureusement ça
devient le quotidien de se faire
agresser ou d'avoir des violences sur
les sur les fonctions de police que
faut-il faire aujourd'hui on leur dit à
chaque fois c'est quoi c'est augmenter
les moyens les moyens financiers les
moyens humains aussi pour les policiers
il ya plusieurs choses en fait les
moyens humains forcément on a besoin on
a besoin d'effectifs comme dans tous les
départements
de france on a besoin d'effectifs et
après on a besoin de moyens financiers
effectivement parce que quand on voit
que les commissariats qui sont vétustes
les voitures de patrouille qui ce qu'ils
ont et qu'ils ont plus de dix ans ah bon
c'est quand même compliqué de travailler
dans de bonnes conditions alors une
deuxième thématique on voulait aborder
avec vous c'est la police de sécurité du
quotidien cette nouvelle force voulue
par emmanuel macron dans 30 quartiers
prioritaires notamment attrape la psq
sera déployé cet automne dans les faits
des effectifs supplémentaires
renforcement de la prévention des
réunions aussi de contacts avec les
habitants en février votre syndicat
s'inquiétait du manque de transparence
sur la nature des missions sur le nombre
d'effectifs prévues pour cette psq
attrapée est-ce que vous en avez appris
plus depuis ce que vous avez été
peut-être rassuré pas du tout quand on
est malheureusement en fait on est
quasiment au même point que au mois de
février
on ne sait toujours pas exactement
quelles seront les missions
déployée pour nous pour nos effectifs de
terrain on attend des sorties d'école
supplémentaire en fin septembre
justement pour pouvoir avoir une
un complément d'effectif pour effectuer
ses missions mais pour l'instant c'est
encore vraiment malheureusement
tellement flou que on ne peut pas
s'avancer sur sur 7 sur cette question
c'est à dire qu'il ya quelques mois de
ce déploiement à attrape vous ne savez
encore pas grand chose finalement de 7
psq de cette police de sécurité du
quotidien tout à fait presque skie
vraiment les grandes lignes ce sera deux
comédiens de rapprocher la le policier
de la population donc d'être beaucoup
plus présent dans les dents dans les
quartiers notamment sur la commune de
trappes
après il va falloir faire un gros
travail je pense que ça va sur le long
terme pour rapprocher les partenaires
sociaux les mairies les instances
sociales les bailleurs sociaux etc
pour avoir un vrai communication avec
avec les acteurs de la police et surtout
ceux qui sont sur le terrain pour
pouvoir faire des bonnes remontées
d'informations nécessaires aujourd'hui
faire du terrain être au plus proche de
la population ou le dit travailler en
étroite collaboration avec différents
partenaires ça c'est primordial
aujourd'hui
bah ça c'est l'avenir qui nous dira
malheureusement pour l'instant on a déjà
eu
l'expérience la mauvaise expérience de
la police de proximité qui avait été
voulue en 1999 on a vu que c'était
finalement un fiasco
donc là on est plutôt méfiant sur le sur
l'avenir on attend de voir
qu'est ce que vous attendez là depuis
enfin jusqu'à ce déploiement pardon à
trappes donc d'en savoir plus on imagine
tu sais ça pour savoir exactement
comment ça va se passer est là pour
l'instant malheureusement on n'a pas
beaucoup d'informations
merci à guillaume lord est revenu sur ce
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes le
secrétaire régional adjoint du syndicat
alliance police nationale dans les
yvelines merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci elles étaient menacées de
disparition mais sauvé finalement grâce
à une reprise par la direction du val
d'oise l'école de la deuxième chance des
yvelines offre chaque année une
formation à 400 jeunes sans
qualification à la nouvelle organisation
était présenté ce matin à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
nouvelle direction pour la structure qui
compte trois sites dans les yvelines
attrape magnanville et aux mureaux et
nouveau projet également qui concerne le
territoire de saint quentin écouter ses
propos au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude et car la vie gens avec des
partenaires plus renforcée des nouvelles
activités
exemple on va lancer dès des formules
métier cirque en nos jeunes pourront
rentrer sur des métiers particuliers
exemple la vente
on va ouvrir à la rentrée une boutique
école dans le centre commercial de saint
quentin en yvelines où les jeunes
pourront s'exercer pour de vrai à la
vente et la gestion d'une boutique avec
la caisse
l'accueil commercial va chalandise d'une
boutique
donc voilà ce qu'on m'a présenté
aujourd'hui à l'ensemble de nos
partenaires
mais jusqu alors ouverte aux seuls 18 25
ans l'école de la deuxième chance d i
mean proposera également dès la rentrée
des formations pour les 15 18 ans en
décrochage scolaire à l'objectif est
d'accueillir 500 jeunes dès 2019 90
mille élèves yvelinois d'élémentaire et
leurs professeurs eux faisait leur
dernier rang
de l'année vendredi à l'école de
lavilledieu d'elancourt c'était aussi la
dernière pour sa directrice anne marie
cruz
après 12 ans passés dans l'établissement
elle a pris sa retraite
mélanie poker a suivi son dernier jour
dans ses fonctions bonjour merci des
cadeaux pour une occasion pour
anne-marie cruz cette ouverture de
portail est très particulière c'est sa
dernière la directrice de l'école
primaire de lavilledieu à elancourt
prend sa retraite
cette dernière année je les très très
bien vécu j'en ai vraiment profité
et j'ai une glace très très sympathique
nous avons eu plein de projets ensemble
c'est un métier alors moi je vis d'une
façon très particulière c'est à dire que
quand j'y suis quand je suis avec mes
élèves quand je suis dans mon école je
n'ai pas l'impression de travailler
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui me pèse
après une carrière dans le secteur privé
puis dans un lycée al marri cruise se
dirige vers l'élémentaire c'est en 2006
qu'elle est amené à diriger cette école
de 240 élèves
après s'être longtemps occupé des cp
elle termine sa carrière avec les cm1 cm
est un jeu l'adorent et j'espère qu'elle
reviendra un jour peut-être pas école
elle était gentille et fois grande est
ce qu'ils n'en portait pas les scènes
vont être très gentil quand il fallait
tu es plus trop gentil et c'était très
sympa cette année on a appris beaucoup
de choses
elle était très gentille je la trouvais
stripped aussi j'aime bien et et je
trouve que c'est une très bonne
maîtresse 32 ans d'enseignement 18 c
comme directrice depuis le 6 juillet
anne marie cruz à fermer ce chapitre de
sa carrière professionnelle
les élèves eux sont partis pour deux
mois de vacances avant de se quitter un
tournoi international de football
féminin il se tenait hier à montigny le
bretonneux vous retrouverez un reportage
sur ce sujet cette semaine dans le
journal
nicolas landry a profité de l'occasion
pour faire le tour des pronostics sur
les demi finales de la coupe du monde de
football en russie
quel vainqueur pour france belgique
demain croatie angleterre mercredi
qui soulèvera le trophée en finale
écoutez ce qu'en pense jose entraîneur
français mais aussi britanniques
présents sur place pour moi c'est la
france qui a gagné
moi hier à 3 2 pour la france buteur
mbacké est doublée de griezmann est
celle la belgique 1 et lukaku est un des
hasards de 1 pour l'équipe de france
avec un but de mbia fait un build up à
clermont manquera pour la france je
pense que la france gagnera 3 et puis en
finale je pense qu'elle rencontrera
l'angleterre
je pense que nous allons battre la
croatie aux tirs au but car nous sommes
très beau aux tirs au but
et bien sûr nous rencontrerons la france
en finale avec je pense que l'angleterre
va battre la croatie et le trophée
reviendra chez lui l'angleterre va
gagner la coupe du monde
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal dans un
instant ne manquez pas la dernière de la
saison du 7-8 sports michael et demi
d'euros vous proposera une rétrospective
et un bilan de la saison sportive dans
les yvelines belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]